foreign
in what Madison Wisconsin what's up
Marie
I see Dr John it's a little surreal to
be talking to you it's very surreal to
be talking to you I promise what's up uh
I am calling Holly and I'll just phrase
my question first but
I would like to know how I can still
possibly help her out but protect my
family and her sanity as she is a child
in an adult body and is making choices
day to day that are devoid from reality
and I can definitely give you kind of
the back story yeah is she a child in
adult body cognitively like she's got
um she's got cognitive impairment or
she's just an adult being a
pretty much the
same okay yeah tell me more I want to
hear this story
so I am an adult skate to go child
um I left home over 12 years ago and
went no contact seven years ago with
very few exceptions literally my
exception is funerals and my grandma's
90th party
um
I am 32. okay all right so I helped my
sister uh who is a doormat or Invisible
Child
um get out about six years ago now and
she only decided to leave quote unquote
after a very uh traumatic event that our
parents had put her through but she
still maintains contact what's that
event
what's that what's the event
the event that I'm calling about today
no what's the traumatic event she
escaped from yeah the traumatic event
that uh she uh had was it's really messy
but
um so there is a a man that showed up
um in our life and
um my parents I have I'm
we're part of a family of eight kids so
I nailed us to the eights um she was the
second and then there's a third one and
the third one is definitely narcissistic
my mother is the narcissist too in the
family if it um helps but the traumatic
event was this man showed up and my
parents were kind of trying to afford he
wanted to be with Kayla Kayla said he
was like quote unquote dating her
secretly and they were forcing him onto
our third sister Teresa and he told her
at some point that he's like I want to
be with you I'm going to date you I'm
gonna tell your parents today and then
what ended up happening was he got there
my dad's like you need to choose you
need to choose anything you're like
pretty much screaming yelling in his
face this is what my sister has informed
me about and she uh
um
she said that she's like all right I
choose District three and Kayla was just
completely devastated after that and
then he just jumped to his car and
laughed and that was it and it's like an
old Bible story like it is yeah it is
how old is your sister
oh gosh this is six plus years ago so
like 20 24 25 when this happened how old
was Sister number three
uh 18 months younger than that so
there's 18 months between the first four
so they were 23 and 24 or 25 living at
home
yep and your dad was trying to arrange
marriage then with this this mystery man
the other man
by the way is
all right this this is like even Jerry
Springer would be like all right that's
that's that's enough of this all right
so so yeah you want to help your sister
so as your sister is she still live at
home is she moved out or what no she
so she just for me a few weeks ago that
she's seven months pregnant closer to
eight now okay and my husband and I just
had our first child here back we've been
married six years so we just had our
first child in January and she claims
that she didn't tell me because we were
expecting our child and she didn't want
to focus me on that and she knew how I
had to react it was more reacting to the
father because as
um I know you know is there's a lot of
repeat with relationships we have to
relive the trauma almost and my sister
has been going to therapy for five years
but she continues with the relationships
where people are emotionally mentally
and financially abusing are all things
in her family did and the father of her
child he is one of those toxic abusive
types and at the time I wrote him we
were aware of four times that he's
cheated
um this is during the first phase of
them dating and second phase started up
again last year and just this week I
learned that she had put a tracker on
his car last year and found out that he
was cheating again so now there's five
total times and
um it was my aunt that told me this not
my sister
um my sister also admitted that he's
financially abused her in the past five
weeks ago she moved in with him okay so
how can I help you what do you want to
do
you can I know I I know but she had
reached out to me and she wanted out
because she called me saying that it was
really messy and how about it
I am very worried about her yeah it's
pretty much of taking care of all my
siblings my whole life I was the not
only a scapegoat but I was the parent
yeah
so and here's what needs to happen
really quick okay and this is just you
and then we can get to the other things
the other people okay
there's part of this frantic I can hear
it in the call there's part of this
frantic
need to be the person who's out like
you're the you're the
the scanner system for everybody in the
family for the brothers and sisters for
who's dating who and your body is
running on drama it's running on
cortisol and adrenaline
that's how it's how you operate and
you've been running that way since you
were a little bitty girl because you
grew up in chaos with really crappy
parents Fair yeah it's fair but I
honestly Dr John I run from Journal
which is why I call because I'm ready to
run again away from this because I don't
want this in my family okay or my family
being my husband my child sure
absolutely so here's the only way it
works to balance I really really love my
family members and I want to take care
of them
and they are
um making really poor decisions and I'm
not gonna allow that poison into my home
because this cycle stops with me yeah
right so here's here's what that means
I'm never the moment somebody starts to
tell me about one of my sister's
boyfriends I'm I'm I end that
conversation done I don't want to hear
it don't care I don't want to hear it
the moment somebody starts talking about
would you hear your sister did she no
don't want to hear it I I I I I'm not
going to engage in that sort of gossipy
conversation I'm clearing my life for
that mess
I will talk to my sister
on a regular basis
of some sort
and if my sister wants my help here's
what that's going to look like
you will get rid of your cell phone you
will never contact this guy again you'll
go to court and get full custody you
like whatever you need to do because
you're not bringing that Insanity into
my house
and I want you in my house here's the
thing she's gonna have to make grown-up
choices yeah
and you're gonna have to make grown-up
choices too but we have to we have to
create a place of of
of Steel and concrete so that anybody
who needs help can anchor into it and
right now you care about them so much
you're willing to dive back into that
mess that you've spent so long healing
from
to an extent I'm not willing to dive
into it which is why I'm calling because
okay that's fair sorry
you know that I know they're going
someplace I will not go good like
because I don't
invited them because my mother being who
she is but
um and hey I I would stop with all
diagnostic language
yeah sorry like no I'm just saying this
like it'll it'll give you peace
well I I mean I'm trained in that and I
don't refer to my friends as like that
guy's got depression and that guy's got
anxiety yeah I don't even do that and I
know all the lingo I just will simply
say yeah that person makes me feel
uncomfortable or that person brings too
much chaos I'm just gonna I'm gonna bow
out yeah okay I don't know if your mom
has narcissistic personality disorder if
she's just mean if she has a lot of
trauma in her childhood here's the deal
it doesn't matter
she treated you like crap and she stole
from you and was abusive and your dad's
track trafficking his adult daughter's
in a weird way like just the whole
thing's just a mess and so yeah I'm out
like I I'll leave your Diagnostics to
the psychiatrist I'm out
um I'm gonna go create a great life and
if you can move across the country
good
I put my foot down I would not move back
to the state that everyone was in yeah I
mean so you're like um so you're proving
me wrong you are really working hard to
heal and that's awesome
this is the one sister that I have
contact with because like I said I
helped her out but she's these choices
she's making now she has a baby girl
that she's about to have is part of me
again this is where my my go-to for
response has always been slight that's
why I'm an workaholic and I know it
but it's just is this the time where I
have to I guess why run again and just
walk and like walk away but always let
her know the door is open when she is
ready to actually make those adult
decisions I think you're done running
okay but I think that you now have gone
out to the front of your property and
built a pretty firm boundary
okay and so I don't want you to look at
saying no as some sort of trauma
response if this is this is you speaking
out of a position of strength and health
this is what healing looks like
unfortunately we think that when we heal
it's gonna be like all right
everything's gonna be awesome
it's not because the world around us
hasn't yet
in fact sometimes getting well healing
and living in a peaceful situation
um can be unnerving one because our
nervous system Only Knows chaos and when
it has no chaos it will either spin it
up and create it or it will try to go
achieve something to make us feel good
we got to get a drilling somewhere right
or um it will feel like depression and
we'll end up just sitting there drinking
or netflixing our lives away and so
I get that impulse but this sounds like
you're operating not from
a trauma response not from running but
it sounds like you were
like you've drawn a hard line
and you can go out to the gates and you
can hand her a piece of paper that says
here's the here's what it will take for
you to come to my home
okay and that can be whatever you and
your husband decide it's going to be
and she needs to know if she comes to
your house or if she becomes a part of
your life here is what will get her sent
away
all right if you bring an abusive man
into this home if you're in contact with
somebody that's abusive you're allowed
to do that but you cannot live here
if you swear if you smoke in the house I
don't care I don't care what it is yeah
um you can you can make any rules you
want because it's your place
yeah
and what you what you can give somebody
over time here's my guess my guess is
she's going to get really mad at you
like you're leaving me like you you're
you're just bailing on me or you're all
high and mighty or you escaped and it's
how lucky it is to be you and all that
nonsense
and you're going to choose guilt over
resentment every single time
because you don't ever want to hate your
sister right
no I I I don't hate my sister yeah I
know but but if she moves into your
house with this new little baby and that
boy comes around and then that boy you
walk in one day and that man is alone
with your kid you know you will hate
your sister we're not going there yeah
we're going to choose guilt we're going
to put strong boundaries up and if
sister doesn't doesn't
um
doesn't live into the boundaries you
make for your life and for your family
then she's opting out and I'm gonna feel
guilty about that because I want to help
her but she's choosing not to not not to
take help right now
yeah right you getting back in that
chaos isn't going to help
is there any way that you know of where
you can because she she's almost
creating a a delusional world right now
because like I said she was open to
moving talk to him and just being who he
is
um it's just she's no
the hair is on our end no the only one
that I know of is constant touches with
reality and that is you deciding I'm
going to write her a letter every week
it just tells her I love her and here's
a great thing that happened and here's
the weather I'm talking about some very
detailed reality things
um or I'm gonna call you once a week and
we're gonna talk for 30 minutes and then
at 30 minutes your watch is going to
beep or your phone's gonna beep and
you're literally gonna say all right I
gotta run
have a great even if it's in the middle
of a of a conversation you're going to
what you're doing is you're you are
modeling in real time what boundaries
look like what peace looks like hey me
and my husband are going on a date
tonight so we got a big romantic one
planned we got a babysitter coming over
so you all have a great night I'm going
on my date oh it must be nice oh my gosh
I wish I yep yeah
it's really incredible and I hope you'll
join me someday have a great one and I'm
hanging up right I'm getting out
um but no there's no way
that you can get involved and make her
choose not this guy who's a gas lighter
and whatever and a whatever and whatever
and a partridge and a pear tree you
can't do anything about that you can
provide an alternative
um an alternative place of peace and
safety for her but she's gonna have to
opt in
and I hate that for both of you I
especially hate it for that little bitty
baby girl that's on the way
because that little baby girl didn't
didn't answer any of this nonsense
but dude I'm proud of you Marie for
getting out I'm proud of you for
creating strong boundaries and saying
not for me and my family not anymore
and I know that that felt like once we
got established everything was going to
be just ah
and it's not sometimes when we heal
our eyes are open to just how chaotic
and madhouse the rest of the world
actually is
create a peaceful home and then create
the boundaries by which people can enter
it and choose guilt over resentment
every time